Hass erfüllt und gefährlich dass die
Worte von Adidas der
Sportartikelhersteller macht schluss
endlich nach langem Hin und Her hat
Adidas die Zusammenarbeit mit Rüpel
Rapper Kanye West nun doch beendet ja
der Grund West hat ja wiederholt
rassistische und antisemitische
Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet jetzt
hat man also in Herzogenaurach nach
langer Zeit und nach großem Druck
endlich die Reißleine gezogen
die Sache mit mir und dem adidas-stil
ist ich kann antisemitische Dinge sagen
und Adidas kann mich nicht fallen lassen
ich kann an diese mythische Dinge sagen
jetzt was und genau das kann der
Sportartikelhersteller doch zwar
erwartet adidas kurzfristig eine
negative Effekt von rund 250 Millionen
Euro im Quartal aber das Unternehmen aus
Herzogenaurach stellt klar es wird kein
Antisemitismus und keine andere Art von
Hassrede geduldet die jüngsten
Äußerungen und Handlungen von Jesu
inakzeptabel hasserfüllt und gefährlich
sie verstoßen gegen die Werte des
Unternehmens wie Vielfalt und Inklusion
gegenseitigen Respekt und Fairness zuvor
hatte der Zentralrat der Juden genau das
gefordert
adidas muss seine Zusammenarbeit mit
Kanye West umgehend einstellen die
täglichen neuen antisemitischen
Entgleisungen des Rappers sind für die
Jüdinnen und Juden in Deutschland und in
aller Welt unerträglich als deutsches
Unternehmen erwarte ich schlichtweg von
Adidas eine klare Haltung wenn es um
Antisemitismus geht
mit der gemeinsamen Kollektion der Yeezy
Schuhe hatten Adidas und Kanye West
Milliarden verdient jetzt ist Schluss
damit die Produktion eingestellt
[Musik]